[Musique]
à temps ou coupe in the dark a
évidemment mais toute l'année et pas
seulement pendant les vacances le
mariage je suis toujours enthousiaste
positif j'avais des gens se marient je
trouve ça très bien être des travaux
dont la carte
évidemment ça sera quand c'est un plus
porte un râteau et dark à caen c'est con
quand ça sourit passera kinder j'ai été
éjecté donc ça sera respectée parce que
j'ai fait des conneries parce qu'ils
m'ont dit c'était afrique
la calvitie à strasbourg ça que j'ai
acheté pour 12 mai bal de shon tournée
en terre plus précisément d'être atteint
je skie alors d'arca puissance pile
barca de puissance en semant d'arca mais
sans plus les choucha je trouve ça
normal que les jeunes trouve ça marrant
et s'amuser dans ce genre de programme
les études rats fera évidemment j'en ai
fait parce que j'avais pas de choix et
ses possibilités et je serais parti en
courant nu et d'une feuille de vigne sur
le sexe et j'aurais couru sur la plage
voilà pour manger des noix de coco quand
je conseille c'est horrible
[Musique]